and it just kills me that on the one
hand we've got all oh gosh no if you if
you criticize somebody you know that
makes them feel bad so we have to make
sure that we don't do that this is harm
reduction okay which we talk about which
is a major impediment to efficiently
running organizations by the way um if
you get to that level and then you got
the people on the other side who just
say you know that they ought to be able
to yell and abuse whoever they want
because they're in charge why is it so
hard to just go okay let's just let's
balance that and reasonably and
responsibly help people get better
instead of trying to tear them
[Music]
down hello everyone watching and
listening today I'm speaking with lawyer
former Washington state senator and now
Federal congressman Adam Smith we
discussed the difficulties and promise
of genuine political dialogue practical
and psychological the dangers of a too
narrow definition of Merit and
accomplishment the difference between
negotiating and winning and topics
related to mental health and political
action outlined in his new book lost and
broken my journey back from chronic pain
and crippling anxiety I've been
attempting to bring Democrats on my
podcast for several years Congressman
Smith is the first sitting House member
or senator for that matter willing to
take the risk and to combat in that
manner the dangerous polarization that
presently confronts
us all right well Congressman Smith
thank you very much for agreeing to talk
to me and to everyone watching and
listening today uh you and I have met a
couple of times before in Washington in
preparation for this uh I've met a lot
of Democrats in was Washington
congressman and Senators many of them
were willing if not pleased to speak
with me there often pleased too I
suppose it's been somewhat tricky
getting Democrats to talk to me on my
podcast for a variety of reasons and so
I think that's unfortunate but I'm
pleased that you have decided to do that
and I I guess I'm probably curious to
begin with why you agreed to do this and
and also what your to accomplish and
then we'll dive into the political mess
a bit sure I mean it has been my sort of
approach to politics from the very start
and I've been doing this a long time I
got elected to the state senate when I
was 25 years old and heck I started that
campaign two years before it ended so
the age of 23 I decided want to run I
wanted to run for office one of the
things I I sort of learned as I
campaigned back then door Belling uh
basically I knocked on every door in my
district well every door of a registered
voter to be perfectly honest about it is
the best thing we can do is be open in
our conversations and as a general rule
um I'll listen to anybody you know I
represent 750,000 people and I represent
every single one of them not just the
ones who voted for me and I have found
that I learn a lot if I'm open to
listening to people particularly people
that I disagree with and then also just
from a messaging standpoint I I
developed a campaign philosophy which is
never let the other side occupy the
space
um so way back when when you know
conservative radio started in the 90s
they wanted me on I went on let's talk I
mean I'm not I'm not afraid of the
conversation um by coming on someone's
show I am not endorsing everything that
they've ever said um I believe that that
is the most effective way to represent
the district and the most effective way
to be a successful politician in general
you I'm regular on Fox News I did Matt
Gates's podcast just a couple weeks ago
um I've been on Tucker Carlson show and
back in the day Sean Hannity I just
believe that's the right way to engage
in general and in this particular moment
when our country is becoming more and
more divided it seems to me like more
and more people are simply deciding you
know part of their decision is who am I
not going to listen to who am I not
going to engage with and I think in a
representative democracy that is an
incredibly dangerous thing to get that
divided so I definitely want to engage
and I you know certainly I I know a
number of people who are big fans of
yours um you have a very wide following
you are an influential person when it
comes to culture and politics and for
any side of the debate to say we're just
going to try to like block that I think
it's incredibly counterproductive as for
what I'm hoping to get out of it um is
just hopefully an informative discussion
whenever I go into these things for the
most part I hope to learn something and
I hope to offer something that the other
person can learn as well you know and
one final point on this is I think too
often now when we're getting engaged in
debates the goal is to force the other
person to agree with you and don't get
me wrong there are moments in politics
and in life when you're trying to do
that you know if if a bill is finally on
the floor of the house and I'm trying to
pass it I'm trying to win an argument
and in that moment I'm going to try to
get as many people as possible to agree
with me but for the most part when
you're engaging with someone your
mission shouldn't be to bludge in the
other side into absolutely agree with
you on everything it should be to learn
it should be grow in your understanding
maybe you're missing something first of
all second of all maybe if you listen to
the other side you will better
understand how to make your own argument
so I always find the most interesting
discussions to be with people who I
don't agree with on everything so to me
it's a logical thing so so there's two
things there I mean the first
is part of the reason to talk to people
with whom you disagree is that you're
going to run into disagreements with
what you think in the world on the from
nature and from culture from other
people from yourself and if you set
yourself up so that you're optimally
challenged by resistance in the abstract
realm through discussion then at least
in principle your ideas are going to be
a lot more battle hardened and tested so
there's no real difference between that
and thinking so so so given
that I'm curious also given the
self-evidence of that and the necessity
of that even in terms of getting your
own idea
straight what do you think it is that's
produced these increasingly insuperable
barriers to communication and also more
specifically why have you got away with
talking to the opposition let's say when
so many other people are appear
increasingly unwilling to do so I mean
you said you know you've talked to all
sorts of reprehensible people on the on
the rightwing side you didn't say
reprehensible I did not say
reprehensible and I don't believe I said
that yes I don't believe reprehensible
yes I said that definitely definitely
and and you know the the the walls
haven't come tumbling down on you now
people are afraid of council culture and
they're afraid of being mobbed and
alienated and they're often afraid of
that if they step across whatever the
Divide happens to be at the moment but
you know by your own testimony you've
been talking to people across the aisle
and the walls haven't fallen down on you
so why is that and and why if that's the
case and it can be done why do you think
so many people are loathed to do it well
I think the biggest reason I'm trying to
figure out how to put this um because
it's
hard okay it is difficult and and and I
will tell you right up front you know
and it's got and also I've been doing
this for a long time I think it's one of
the benefits if you take me back to in
my 20s and everything I devel I would
develop strong opinions about thing I'm
a very passionate person I believe
strongly in a number of different things
and I believe in advocating for them and
I I would build up to a good belief and
then I'd run into someone who would say
a bunch of things that I hadn't thought
of and it's an incredibly unsettling
experience all right um because first of
all you're like oh my goodness I I I
just I put my myself out there and am I
wrong okay am I missing some huge thing
and I sort of run back in my mind I was
just at this event and I just told these
people this is the way it is this is the
way it has to be and oh my gosh I've
spread this message and and and I'm
wrong yeah um you know so it's difficult
in that regard and then whenever that
happens there's I think um off the top
of my head two possibilities one um you
are in fact wrong you missed something
something that is crucial to what your
position is or two the argument has come
at you that you haven't had the chance
to think your way through it okay
because I frequently will get hit with
things and this happens a lot when we're
debating an issue in the armed services
committee I prepare for a lot of it but
a lot of it it's happening okay and it's
it's always joke after the debate you're
like oh I should have made that point
you know that would that would you know
so so and but that's hard okay it's
really hard to go back and okay how do I
counter that argument I know what I
believe I believe it if I can just go
out there and say it but now I got to
counter this so I think a lot of people
are drawn to the easier thing and the
easier thing is oh all these people
preach into the choir I mean pick your
favorite cliche at this point and that's
one of the big things one of the reasons
actually why I mean and certainly there
are things you and I disagree on but
from what I've seen of your speeches and
from our conversations you are a
believer in doing things that are
difficult and the inherent benefit that
comes to us as human beings from doing
that and so am I um but by definition
it's not easy okay and as human beings
we are as I said I think before we
started this we're incredibly adaptable
and that's what I learned from my own
personal experience when I went through
my mental health and my um you know um
physical health problems is human beings
are incredibly capable of getting better
all right if you work at it that's
number one but number two it is rarely
our first inclination to do something
that's
uncomfortable we we are going to look
for the more comfortable option just
instinctively so you have to fight that
instinct it's not easy it's not easy to
do the thing that's uncomfortable that's
going to make you better um and I think
a lot of people struggle with that and
of course modern technology makes it
very easy to never have to encounter
things that you don't agree with you can
you can filter every aspect pect of your
life to make sure it stays in the lane
you want to stay in final point on this
don't want to give a long-winded answer
the second question here but is you know
I think it's the reason people say wow
we never talk about politics and
religion okay what's the what's the fun
in that okay you know how do we learn
and grow if we don't talk about the
things that make us un a little bit
uncomfortable so that we can better
understand each other and not be off in
our own little Corners thinking all
kinds of awful terrible things about
each other and then never never trying
to bridge that that
divide so by temperament I a very
agreeable person which is a rather
feminine trait because women tend to be
more agreeable than men and agreeable
people don't like conflict and I've been
embroiled in a lot of conflict and
there's a very specific reason for that
and the reason is is that I learned
mostly through clinical experience
although that wasn't all of it that
conflict delayed is conflict multiplied
and you know you pointed out
that it's challenging to be shown to be
wrong and the reason for that I've
looked at this technically the reason
for that is that our beliefs Orient us
like a person is oriented in with a map
and if you find out that your map is
wrong then you don't know where you are
and you don't know where you're going
and that produces anxiety and
hopelessness and the bigger the akake
the more of the map is uh invalidated
and that's very
disorienting profoundly disorienting we
don't like to be lost and so then you
might say well why would you ever bother
challenging your beliefs or engaging in
conflict with someone and the answer to
that this is a bit of a reiteration but
the answer to that is quite clear it's a
lot better to have your ideas tested in
the abstract than it is to have your
convictions demolished by reality itself
and and so you need to this is partly
what I think has gone wrong for example
in the education system Lucen off has
written a fair bit about this along with
Jonathan height is that we believe that
students because of the fragility of
their mental health should be shielded
from uncomfortable conversations let's
say or uncon uncomfortable conversations
and the clinical reality is very very
clear it's very clear this is one thing
that all reliable clinicians have agreed
upon over a 50-year period which is that
voluntary encounter with what you're
afraid of and even potentially disgusted
by is clearly salutary and Curative and
so you want
to give people a hair of the dog that
bit them constantly right to fortify
them against Challenge and the best way
to do that is to engage voluntarily in
the exchange of of ideas of
representations so and the reason I'm
dwelling on this in part is because
people might be listening and thinking
why in the hell should I ever have a
difficult conversation why should I ever
talk to someone who disagrees with me
and the answer is well you if you're
100% about right right about everything
and you're currently living in Paradise
itself and everything in your life is as
good as it can possibly be then you
don't ever have to encounter a negative
opinion because you've got everything
right but if there's some
un unfurrowed corner of your soul that
still isn't in the order that it could
be and you're you're feeling that as a
consequence of your own suffering then
you should be out there testing your
ideas against everything you possibly
can on the off chance that you might be
fortunate enough to learn how you're
stupid and wrong so you can stop being
both of those and of course that's
painful but it's not as painful as being
stupid and wrong
Souls well I mean a couple things about
them me first of all I'm with you I you
know as I document I I grew up a very
anxious person I I did not like conflict
either because I had massive
insecurities um psychological issues
that became significant problems later
in life so yeah right there with you
because I think it's worth pointing out
that there are some people who like
conflict and seek it out um and that's
not a good thing um and that's sort of
brings me my third point and dealing
what you're talking about to me it's all
about balance and that's something that
we've sort of lost and again I think
part of the problem is balance is
difficult you tell me that in every
situation this is the way it is all
right I'm good I know what to do you
tell me in every situation that it's
great but if you tell me well it depends
okay you know what did the person say
what are the circumstances well then
you're back into a situation where you
got to work pretty hard to figure out
what the right way to be is and that's
hard but that's life we need to teach
people how to balance that and I'm
completely with you
on the fact that in our education system
and in many aspects of our life right
now we do not teach resilience okay we
teach people to be protected now the one
caveat I'll throw out there is a lot of
these people who like conflict you know
get to the point where they take a
certain amount of joy in putting people
in difficult circumstances which is not
for any clinically beneficial person
it's just because they're being jerks so
you can Empower a lot of people acting
like jerks by saying well of course we
have to test them so you always have to
try to have a balance here the purpose
of conflict is to help people get better
and you have to understand that purpose
of conflict is not so that you can
attack somebody all right I see this
frankly a lot of times in parenting um
it's really important I have a 23 and a
20- year old child so but my wife and I
have raised two children now and have
experienced this and we're human we're
trying to educate our children along the
way teach them how to be better but then
also we got our own stuff going on here
here okay so when you're getting angry
at a child is it because you're trying
to make them better or is because you're
trying to score a point and you really
need to try to figure out how to balance
that and I think a lot of people don't
so if you can balance those two things
it's fine I mean I'm completely with you
on the resilience thing um but but you
also have to guard against resilience
being just an excuse to abuse somebody
so with regard to scoring a
point so you imagine that there are two
ways of establishing a modum of
psychological and possibly social
stability and one would be to negotiate
a settlement voluntarily so that you and
I could exchange our opinions and come
to a negotiated agreement about the
nature of the present and about the
nature of the desirable future right now
the advantage to that is that if it's
voluntarily negotiated you can go off on
your own and I can go off on my own
we'll walk down the same path without a
lot of mutual ual um without a lot of
mutual supervision so that's very
helpful another alternative though is to
attain a certain degree of comparative
status and so it turns out that the
serotonin
system monitors comparative status and
so if I score a point on you in
principle that elevates my status above
you and then you might ask well what's
the advantage to that and the advantage
to status acquisition is a raise in
central serotonergic function and that
dampens negative
emotion and so you can imag you can
imagine there's two deep places there's
two deep sources of the conflict between
two different approaches to problem
solving right if I can attain
comparative status this is people are
trying to obtain comparative status very
constantly in our culture often without
doing the requisite effort but the
advantage to that is that the status
boost does produce a quelling of
negative emotion now it's not as good a
solution as a negotiated piece the
problem with a negotiated piece is that
you have to wander through the bloody
disagreement and sort out all the
intervening uh conflicts in order to
establish the peace if I could try to
put it a little bit bit more simply when
you're having a discussion with somebody
are you trying to solve a problem are
you trying to get to a fair result or
are you trying to win
okay and there's a big difference and I
think in a lot of the disagreements out
there in the world too often now people
are trying to win okay they're trying to
own the other side me temperamentally I
don't know why but I'm I'm a peacemaker
well I think it's partially because I
grew up anxious and there were you know
things in my family that were a little
disruptive and I just want peace and
stability and I learned early on and
it's not that it's it's not that I'm not
selfish and not passionate and don't
have things that I personally want but
as I grew I realize that that above all
of those things is I wanted a peaceful
environment around me and if I'm going
to achieve a peaceful environment around
me I have to care what other people want
and what other people think too and you
have to work at that and that's where I
think the conflict goes I think you're
right I you do you get that initial High
I was right you know now I'm going to
win the argument now everybody has to do
what I say from here on out because I've
proven that I am the superior intellect
in this place it's like yeah that
doesn't work too well past a certain
point we all have our ups and downs and
again I really want to emphasize this
point you know I've negotiated a lot of
things over what is it now 33 years that
I've been an elected official um and
it's so crucial if you've gone to
negotiate something actually I'll quote
something to a good friend of mine who's
a very successful businessman told me if
he's involved in a business deal and
when it's all over said and done with he
got everything he wanted he knows he did
it wrong okay right because it's got to
be about how we keep everybody on board
and I worry that as we become more
dogmatic in our politics and our
business in our my gosh in in Little
League for crying out loud you know it's
like no we have to win we have to be the
one on top we have to it's
like okay but you're in for a whole lot
of conflict if you don't care at least a
little bit about whether or not the
community as a whole was getting to a
fair place okay so so that's a great seg
way as far as I'm concerned into a
political issue that I've been longing
to hash out with the Democrats for
example who will talk to me and I'd like
to explain momentarily why I'm not a fan
of identity politics and it's relevant I
think it's relevant to the concerns that
you just laid out it's incredibly
relevant yes okay so so
so what I see happening in the broad
culture and this is part of the culture
war is this increasing insistence that I
can Define myself in precisely the terms
that I want to Define myself now that
tends to devolve into something like
sexual identification or ethnic
identification or some other group
identification which is also something I
think is incredibly dangerous but but
here's the problem with this and I I've
been trying to think it through from the
perspective of a psychotherapist on the
one hand I could claim that one of my
clients for example has the perfect
right to Define themselves subjectively
but that runs into to a number of
problems and the problems are for
example that sometimes people's
subjective
self-identification is clearly
counterproductive so anorexics for
example think they're too fat when in
fact they're generally on the verge of
absolute starvation and people who are
manic get an very expanded sense of
self-confidence and believe that they
can do all sorts of things that they
can't and that they have resources that
they don't and so forth almost
everything about Psychotherapy is
actually about identity and so it's
clearly the case that you cannot
merely identify yourself subjectively
and proceed appropriately in the world
on that basis and here's why I believe
and this is partly I think what's tilted
me more towards conservatism in so far
as I am tilted in that direction so
psychotherapists who are inheritors of a
kind of a Protestant and humanistic
tradition
have presumed that mental health is
something that you that characterizes
the structure of your psyche it's
something internal and I think that
that's incorrect I think that what
mental health is is the net benefit of
experiencing a harmonious nested
relationship with the broader community
so it's very difficult to be sane if
you're not getting along with your wife
and you and your wife can't be sane if
you're not getting along with your
children children and your family can't
be Sayan if you're having a scrap with
your local community and the local
community can't be Saye if it's not well
integrated into the town and the state
and the nation and then whatever might
happen to be above that and so the the
right manner of conceptualizing mental
health is that it's the manifestation of
the harmony that comes from having the
hierarchy of being put in its proper
place now when we turn to subjective
self-identification on the sexual or
ethnic front for example the insistence
that I am whoever I say I am the problem
with that is well what the hell are the
other people supposed to do I mean
you've been married for for decades you
have kids you know you know 30 years
congratulations I just had my 34th this
week um you know perfectly well that and
and this is Germaine also to your point
about conflict is that you have to
establish a negotiate peace in order for
stability to maintain itself and
negotiation what you're negotiating
constantly as far as I can tell is your
identity right and so AB so I'm very
concerned about okay so what so first of
all do you think that that's those
observations are relevant to the culture
War that's raging now not least over
subjective self identification and and
uh what What's your opinion about how
the political landscape has laid itself
out around those issues sure I think
it's very relevant let let make couple
quick points to walk through this first
of all yeah and we haven't talked about
it but I keep making references to
physical mental pain I I went through a
severe anxiety problem severe chronic I
wrote a book about it um which sort of
outlined how I got through that when you
started talking about Psychotherapy I
went through three and a half years of
psychotherapy that was enormously
helpful and I think you're right your
your your internal mental health is
going to be dictated a lot by your
relationships I would say in defense of
the the psychotherapists out there in
the world your ability to have those
positive relationships has a lot to do
with your own internal mind and whether
or not you are psychologically stable
person whether or not you've dealt with
the issues in your life so just that
little quick shout out to the
psychotherapists I think there is an
important component of that second I
think you're you're you're working your
way around the the broader culture issue
that that we have and I think it is
incredibly important I tell you I I read
Christopher rufo's book um along the
lines of me being engaged that and I I
spoke to Chris just last week um and
walked through some of this and you're
getting down sort of into the granular
level of okay what has happened as an
outgrowth of our concern about racism
bigotry and discrimination and the
conversations that people have had about
how identity factors into that but I
think the big problem and the thing that
I hope and I can try to convince folks
on the conservative side of this that
when it comes to the fight and the
battle that we have and certainly I
think Christopher rufo did a pretty good
job of outlining some of the more
extreme elements of the left approach to
this but what motivates people like me
is the fact that racism bigotry and
discrimination are problems in American
society they are okay you can't fairly
look at the history of the United States
and conclude otherwise now I also think
you can't fairly look at the history of
the United States and conclude that
that's all we've ever been about okay is
racism bigotry and discrimination I
think as with most things it's a balance
and there's a lot of things going on I
think the problem I have with the
conservative movement I had this
conversation with Mr ruo is yes what the
left is doing is problematic but the
right conservatives Republicans they
don't offer a reasonable alternative
because their alternative is racism and
bigotry aren't really a problem let's
just stop worrying about it and move on
okay and and logically I have all kinds
of problems with that approach so then
we get trapped between you know the far
right um in terms of how they want to
approach that and the farle and their
very specific way of approaching it and
to answer one of your earlier questions
that I skipped over as to as to why I
can be successful doing this I think the
overwhelming majority of people are in
fact looking for what I'm talking about
an open and engaging approach they're
just not offered it altogether that
often um and that's where we're trapped
in identity politics is these two
extremes okay you know racism bigotry
and discrimination is everything every
single decision every single thought
you've ever had has to be focused on
identity and then the other side not a
problem not we're thinking about there's
a lot in between there that I think we
could work on to build a better
Society it's time to take your fault
style to the next level dressing for
Success can help you look better and be
more confident so whether you're
attending an important meeting or
networking event or simply want to
impress your colleagues mizen and Main
has everything you need their clothing
is comfortable breathable packable and
machine washable their dress shirts are
designed to help you close out the year
in style whether you're shopping for a
special someone this holiday season or
giving yourself the gift you really want
mizen and Maine is the perfect gift for
any guy who works travels plays golf or
wants to look and feel great and let's
be honest that's every guy so what are
you waiting for spruce up your fall
Style with mizen and Main go to m
and.com and use code Jordan to get 25%
off any purchase of $130 or more that's
M zzen
and.com promo code Jordan for 25% off
[Music]
today so when I've gone to
Washington and and spoken in this case
primarily to Democrats I've also worked
with the Democrats a lot I worked with a
group of people in California my friend
and former student Greg
herwitz um on Democrat messaging for
about five years and I've had a lot of
conversation with Democrats and one of
the things I've often asked them this is
a very complicated problem is when does
the left go too far and it's a
complicated problem for a variety of
reasons I would say
the first reason is is that most of the
excesses on the Progressive
left make themselves camouflage
themselves in the guise of compassion
now I know there are Bad actors on both
side of the political Spectrum there's
Bad actors in the religious domain
there's Bad actors in the scientific
domain and these are always people they
have a very identifiable set of
personality characteristics generally
bordering on the psychopathic that will
use a moral St St to put forward their
own agenda instrumentally or to torment
other people and there's a very
well-developed psychological literature
indicating this and the the problem
there is that boundaries have to be
drawn
to stop those actors the psychopathic
types from invading the general culture
and taking it out and a small proportion
of people like that can do that um
psychopaths in general by the way run
about 3% of the population that's about
as successful as they ever get but
they're an omnipresent threat to
cultural stability well I guess that's a
little lower lower than I thought so
I'll I'll take that as good news but uh
yeah yeah well it is good news because
it means that 95% of people aren't like
that it's very good news now the bad
news is that it doesn't take very many
people like that to cause an awful lot
of trouble now the other thing that
happens on the left and this is
different than the right is that people
on the left do have
more difficulty temperamentally drawing
boundaries and you can see this in the
rhetoric that right and left use well
I'm this isn't a criticism exactly no no
I'm I'm just think a boundary a boundary
can keep good things out just as much as
it can keep bad things out and so the
liberal bet especially the the leftist
bet is the more information that flows
freely the better off everyone is and
the conservative rejoinder is yeah but
not all information because some things
are so toxic they can't be digested and
then the discussion is well what should
we allow in and what's too toxic to be
digested and that's con that has to be
constantly discussed because it shifts
and changes that's part of the reason
why free speech is necessary but what
I've observed like I've asked for
example virtually every Democrat I've
ever come in contact with when does the
left go too far I'm I'm going to
decorate that with one other observation
so one of the disciplines I studied
social psychology the social
psychologists insisted for 70 years that
there was no such thing as left leftwing
authoritarianism that didn't crack until
2016 yeah well right that's utterly
insane but but it is actually
Troublesome because it is harder to
point to an ex to excesses on the left
and to say well there's a policy that
purports to be put forward in a
compassionate manner that's actually not
that at all and that's highly toxic and
so you've been involved in the scrum of
Washington politics for a long time I
asked Robert Kennedy this question and
he said before bloody YouTube took our
my conversation with him down um he said
I don't he said essentially that he
didn't want to answer that because he
wasn't trying to run a campaign of
divisiveness and you know fair enough
but it it
it doesn't get to the heart of it we
have a culture war going on there's
excesses on both sides a fair bit of
it's driven by psychopathy it isn't
obvious to me that the Democrats have
done a good job of drawing a dividing
line between them and the people who are
you know the moderate Democrats who I
know are most of them and the and the
small minority of extreme radicals who
have a disproportionate influence and so
well I'm curious about what you think
about that and well so you went in a
whole bunch of different directions here
and let me try to make sure I can can
can sift through it I mean first of all
you know on your point about there's no
such thing as leftwing authoritarianism
I've stayed in regular contact with some
pretty hardcore conservative people over
the years and a number of them have
argued with me that there's there's no
such thing as right-wing violence okay
so when it when it comes to that ability
to try to like I don't know twist the
world to fit your ideology I haven't
noticed any particular difference
between the the the left and the right
on that they both are capable of it
second you rais a really interesting
point uh which I will just mention
briefly and not go down that rap not a
rabbit hole won't go down that that
discussion because I want to get back
into that you know when does the let go
too far question but yeah I I went to
forom University which is a fascinating
place to go to I'm not Catholic um I I'm
an episcop bilion I thought about
becoming a Catholic after leaving forom
and the primary reason that I didn't is
because it's too much work okay I was 23
years old they said well you got to go
to classes for 6 months and I'm like I
went to classes for like a month and I
was like I don't want to do that anyway
minor point but anyway I took a class
things is interesting about forom
particularly forom in the 80s I don't
know about now um is you know Jesuit
schools have both some really really
left-leaning professors and then some
hardcore conservative professors as well
and I had this this professor I took a
class with um about Edmund Burke um and
sort of studying the importance of
tradition and this was a very
conservative Professor who was pro-life
and at one point during our discussion
he said you know the worst thing our
country ever did was to allow people to
debate abortion and at the time I was 21
years old I had a very Li liberal mind
my parents had raised me that you know
we have open debate we do all this other
stuff and you know and it was just it
struck me as like just who is this guy
you know saying that we shouldn't even
talk about it but when you stop and
think about it from a logical standpoint
he was CW life he didn't want any
abortion to be legal at all it was
illegal so if we didn't talk about it
he was going to stay up top so that's
that's an interesting little debate
about how much Freedom of Information
you know depending on what you're trying
to accomplish personally I'm with you
the more we talk about it the more we
get to the right answers is what I
believe on on that front but on your
question you know when does the left go
too far when does the right go too far
one of the things I've discovered is
it's best not to engage in that type of
conversation I take a vastly more
practical approach to it and I will
specifically explain what you mean and
then I will answer that that that
question so when I look around the
Seattle King County area that I
represent my District's now entirely
within King County it's changed over the
course of my 27 years of representing it
um we have a significant problem with
some very specific issues we have a
problem with homelessness we have a
problem with drug abuse we have a
problem with crime and we have a problem
with affordable housing all right so
when I dive into this I don't dive into
it going okay who's the who let
happen um I dive into it like okay what
are we going to do about it all right
what's working what's not working how do
we how do we actually get to the point
where we better address those issues and
within that context um the the specific
answer to your question as to what's
problematic is that the left has moved
too far in the direction of let's look
at the broader societal causes of these
things which by the way is important it
is okay you know if you have more
Economic Opportunity if you have better
access to health care if you have better
access to education all of those things
that I just mentioned with the possible
exception of the affordable housing
problem which is complicated um get
better that is true but if you take
individual responsibility completely out
of the equation and say we're just going
to look at grer societal problems that's
where you get into trouble we need to
get a balance and I've had this
conversation with a number of different
folks community- based organizations
County government city government as I'm
trying to sort of work through this and
I asked the question you know well okay
broader societal stuff I get but what
role does individual Choice play in a
decision to abuse drugs in a decision to
commit crime and frequently the answer I
get back is well it really doesn't which
is which is wrong okay I mean I you know
I'm not getting getting into some
broader ideological oh my gosh you've
gone too far you I don't care about that
you're you're adopting a policy that is
going to make it more difficult to
actually help people and I'm Progressive
on this I believe in alternatives to
incarceration okay I believe in you know
getting people into treatment so you've
got that's issue one is is there any
individual responsibility here do we set
expectations for people do we hold them
accountable for their actions and and
out a level okay you don't take a
homeless drug addict with a mental
problem and say okay you got to go to
work 40 hours a week starting right now
no okay I get that but you could be a
little something okay let's let's do a
little something today we'll do a little
more tomorrow and we'll do a little more
the next day they're rejecting that and
then the second problem is individual
agency okay and I also that's point I I
believe in that okay you know you can't
just again grab somebody pull them off
the street Street throw them in a me
mental hospital and tell them to get
better okay you want to work with them
to get to the point where they're making
individual choices but they're making
the right choices and I think we've gone
too far in the other direction of look
we can't tell this person what they
should do okay when they're ready okay
they they'll they'll seek treatment when
they're ready they'll move on this it's
a lot more of a balance okay and I think
in our approach looking at the broader
system societal issues also looking at
some of the authoritarian problems I
mean look we incarcerated too many
people in this country over the course
of 60 60 years it became the easy button
for public policy and it ruined a lot of
lives it absolutely did and we should
fix that but you don't have to go all
the way over to the other side where
okay we can abolish the whole criminal
justice system and everything will be
fine the problem we run into in our
community is so we've got a lot of
people pushing that that that further
out agenda on those two issues and then
as I keep saying what's the conservative
alternative the conservative alternative
is well let's just keep locking them up
and let's pretend that racism doesn't
exist well my community isn't going to
go for that I'm not going to go for that
you know I think we need a more balanced
approach but that fundamentally to
answer your question of it'd be wrong to
say and when we spoke once you you put
the question is what what is the
Democratic party doing wrong Democratic
part is a big amorphous thing you put
the question a little differently today
what is the left doing wrong um I would
say those are the two issues we need a
better balance that takes into account
personal responsibility individual
choice and the need to help people get
to a better place I I've taken to
summing it up from a meeting I had a
week ago you know the phrase meet people
where they are I completely agree with
that it's long been My Philosophy when
I'm trying to pass a bill or get a vote
I got to understand that person before I
I'm not going to come in and tell them
to be something different so meet people
where they are I amend that to say yes
but don't leave them there okay you know
yes person homeless they got all these
difficulties now what are we going to do
to help them get to a better place that
is the way I would describe that that
challenge so I agree with you in
relationship to the dir of let's say
conservative alternative alternative
Vision I think that's a real weakness on
the conservative side and maybe even
more specifically on the Republican side
so we can return to that later I wanted
to embellish your comments about agency
and responsibility a bit so technically
there's not much difference between
agency and
hope they they run on the same
neurological circuit so if you believe
you can do something well that's a
hopeful vision and hope is positive
emotion broadly speaking it's mediated
by the systems that produce positive
emotion and indicates the probability of
successful movement forward and so by
attributing all problems to society you
risk removing individual agency and the
consequence of removing individual
agency is you destroy hope and that's
not a positive thing and then there's
another element that plays into that
that I'd be interested I want your
opinions on all of this but one of the
things I've noticed as I've traveled
around the world speaking to my
audiences let's say the people who come
to listen and and to consider is that if
I draw a relationship between
responsibility and meaning the crowd
always falls silent and the the reason
for that as far as I can tell is that
the meaning that sustains Us in life is
actually a consequence not so much of
having the right to do whatever we want
so that would be on the hedonic side
which can lead to a very short-term and
impulsive orientation self-centered
orientation instead it's the res the
meaning emerges as a consequence of
bearing the responsibility for yourself
and for your partner and for your family
and for your community I mean literally
that's where the meaning comes from and
if that's demolished and that's on the
personal responsibility side if that's
demolished you leave people B of meaning
and that is one of the dangers of
abstracting the diagnosis of societal
problems all the way up to the to the
highest level of social organization you
know the pathology of the patriarchy is
that you demolish the domain of useful
attention and action on the individual
side and I also think that that's one of
the cardinal sins let's say of the
radical left is that it's that
combination of excessive abstraction and
also the now the leftists their their
point fundamentally is well how do you
discriminate assigning responsibility
from laying
blame right I mean well and that's it's
really a good question and you always
wrestle with in Psychotherapy you know
if I have a client I personally don't
think it's that hard I'm with you
everyone I run into says it is but
having been a parent the way you do that
is it's it's almost a matter of cone
okay you know you can have a
conversation with your child when you've
done something wrong and I had when I
try not to drag my children too much
into this but I can think some specific
conversations when you calmly walk
through an explanation of here's what
you did here's the choice you made
here's why it was a problem or you just
scream at them for being terrible awful
horrible human beings okay to me that's
how you differentiate okay blame is an
affirmative you're you know
responsibility is just okay we're all
flawed we're all humans you know we're
all going to screw things up I'm not
saying because you did that wrong okay
that that means you're a terrible awful
horrible human being and I can't stand
to look at you okay but you did
something wrong so let's not pretend
that that didn't happen just CU it's
going to make you feel bad to realize
that you did something wrong let's have
a professional grownup kind caring
helpful conversation about how you can
do it better and it just kills me that
on the one hand we've got all oh gosh no
if you if you criticize somebody you
know that makes them feel bad so we have
to make sure that we don't do that this
is harm reduction okay which we talk
about which is a major impediment to
efficiently running organizations by the
way um if you to that level and then you
got the people on the other side who
just say you know that they ought to be
able to yell and abuse whoever they want
because they're in charge why is it so
hard you you you you delve into the mind
a lot more than I do why is it so hard
to just go okay let's just let's balance
that and reasonably and
responsibly help people get better
instead of trying to tear them
down according to a recent report
Planned Parenthood continues to rake in
billions to despite dwindling clients
the biggest takeaway here is that
Planned Parenthood is generating vast
profits including millions in taxpayer
funding with the help of pre-born you
and me we are stealing their clientele
meaning the babies they are trying to
kill pre-born operates on a very slim
budget as they rescue over 200 babies
lives every day and they receive no
Government funding pre-born network of
clinics are situated in the darkest
corners competing head-to-head with the
abortion Giants they need our help now
more than ever when you donate $28 to
pre-born you will offer a free
ultrasound to an expectant mother caught
in crisis once she hears that Harpy and
sees that precious life her baby's
chance at life doubles if you would like
to sponsor a precious baby's life your
gift will be tax deductible and will go
directly towards saving babies lives
dial pound 250 and say the keyword baby
or visit preborn
docomo all gifts are tax deductible you
will never regret saving a child's life
that's pound 250 baby or visit preborn
docomo well it's it's part of the
problem that you point to in your book
and your book I thought I'd just uh
point this out to everyone the book is
called let me I've got it written down
here I want to get it exactly right lost
and broken my journey back from chronic
pain and crippling anxiety one of the
things you discuss in that book is the
difficulty of diagnosis and this is
relevant with regard to the judicious uh
decisions and conversations that are
necessary in assigning responsibility
and you might ask well why bother
calling your kids out on something
they've done wrong if it hurts their
feelings and certainly parents will
avoid doing that especially if they're
the kind of parents that Foster
dependence but the answer is well if
your child did something stupid that
hurt them and other people in a manner
that's counterproductive if continued
the price they have to pay to realize
that flaw
is offset by the advantage of not doing
the stupid thing again now the the
diagnostic complexity is toold right one
is first of all things are complex and
deciding how someone went to hell in a
hand basket parsing that up the
responsibility up there with regard to
social contribution familial
contribution and individual
responsibility I mean that can take
hundreds of hours of dialogue it's very
very complicated so complexity is part
of it and then the
the conflict that might come along with
mediating responsibility and blame
that's difficult you know if you're
talking to your kids they might say well
you know if you weren't such a son of a
I wouldn't be so
rebellious and that's you know that's a
perfectly reasonable potential
proposition but there's no shortage of
conflict that has to be had in sorting
that out and of course one other lay one
other layer on that I just want to throw
in is so I have two children and and I'm
married and when you're like negotiating
between okay an argument between like my
son and my wife or my son my daughter
then it's like okay well what about what
they did all right and then that that
throws in a little bit more complexity
as well personally I think it's all
navigable like guess you can work your
way through it let's put it that way
it's not easy for the reasons you
describe but I I think it is more doable
than most people give it credit for it
that's all I'm saying well the
alternative is to put your head in the
sand and continue to get kicked as a
consequence or to degenerate into out
outright conflict I mean it's either
it's negotiation slavery or tyranny
those are the fundamental options and so
well on that front one of the things
I've also viewed and you can help me
with this if you would is I'm
watching you guys in the US tear
yourselves apart we're doing it to some
degree in
Canada with regard to the idea of um
systemic racism let's say now you
pointed out out quite rightly that the
proclivity to alienate and manifest
Prejudice because of innate group
differences is
pervasive and I think the
anthropological literature suggests that
you know most tribal groups around the
world describe their people as human and
everyone else is non-human it's an
extraordinarily common linguistic C
categorization proclivity and so I think
you can make a strong hsian case that
although people are cooperative and will
reach across the aisle that generally we
tend to think of the people like us as
human and the people who aren't like us
as not human and so out of that comes
just to be clear I don't bias and racism
I don't know that I would go quite that
far I I would say we tend to be tribal
we tend to think of the group that we
belong to as being somehow better than
other groups I don't know that we
necessarily decide that other groups
aren't human just that there's the
tendency to think that you're better and
that will vary obviously situation to
situation but it it is a human tendency
yeah you see you it it's complex because
obviously tribal groups can trade and
intermingle and so there is a
countervailing tendency but the
linguistic tendency is literally to
define the non-tribal members as not
human now I'm not saying that we
necessarily do that fully but we can
easily be tempted in that direction now
the radical leftist critique of American
society is that the society itself is
systemically racist and this actually
really bothers me as an outside Observer
and an admirer of the American system
now the Canadian system is quite similar
although we're doing everything we can
to muck it up at the moment but you see
my sense is exactly the opposite which
is that the proclivity for systemic bias
and racism is deeply rooted in the human
soul and it's a a bloody miracle that
there was any progress there's ever been
any progress made in that direction at
all and I would say that your Society
grounded as it is in a broader UK
tradition is the Stellar example of the
counterveiling tendency which is to
attribute to all human Souls something
approximating Divine value regardless of
the particulars of their group identity
and so then when I see these radical
critiques of American societ
accusing it of systemic racism and being
even founded on those principles I think
this is very counterproductive because
not only is it not the case it's
actually the case that the uk/ American
tradition that has made of slavery let's
say an absolute moral evil is rare and
most pronounced in the case of while the
anglo-american tradition and so what I
see happening with the radical left for
example is they're actually throwing out
the very thing that they purport to
support because well and you can tell me
what you think about
this the idea that might makes right and
that if I can force you into servitude I
have the I have the right to do that
that's pretty damn self-evident the
notion that you have some intrinsic
worth even if you're weak and easily
what would you say easily manipulated
and forced that you still have some
worth that's a very difficult
proposition to put forward and yet both
the UK and the US managed it and
whatever degree of true interracial
Harmony and freedom has prevailed
particularly in the west particularly in
the US is actually a consequence of that
counterveiling tendency and I think
that's the fundamental forward thrust of
the American Enterprise so when I see
the leftists go after that and they and
that's something that's become
increasingly dogmatically taught in
universities I than God you guys you
know you're killing the very thing that
in principle has been the closest thing
to Bringing about what you want that's
ever made itself manifest in history
yeah I mean I think you've hit upon what
is you know one of the principal
divisive issues in American politics
that is making things more difficult to
get things done because people are
locked into that debate um which side is
going to win that debate and as I've
said a couple of times and we'll likely
say more more frequently as this
interview progresses I take a more
practical problemsolving approach to
things um and it's you know what do we
need to do to build a better Society now
when it comes you know what what is
America founded on it's no one thing um
and it's no one thing to one group of
people I tend to agree with you that the
principal idea is equality is the idea
that we are not going to be as tribal
that's certainly what the document said
but I think the thing to remember you
know for for conservatives is this
approach to dealing with racism bigotry
and discrimination didn't come from
nowhere okay it came from in addition to
all those Traditions that you rightly
just describe we've had a pretty rich
history of also some pretty thorough
discrimination now that's that's changed
um gotten better I confidently assert
over the course of the last 60 years but
for much of American history I mean let
let's start with you know the the
founding principles of everyone should
have a say in how they are govern
democracy which was one of the big ideas
that we tried to introduce well at the
time we introduced it everyone knows I
mean it applied to white male property
owners and that was it now my personal
take on this is at the time we did that
democracy in its trueu sense really
didn't exist anywhere on the globe um so
to take that step was a significant step
and ever since then we've been expanding
on that okay we've been trying to get
better at it but also along the way
incredible history of you know white
supremacist white supremacy patriarchy
um all manner of discrim discrimination
that have in fact been more locked in to
how we've governed ourselves than most
people realize and I'll give you just
one one example and then expand out on
how I think we should handle this and I
agree with you the way the far-left is
handling it I don't agree with okay I
also don't agree with the way the right
is handling it but you know we have this
debate and this something that I led the
the fight on in Congress to rename
military bases in our country we have a
lot of military bases and installations
and other things ships that were named
after Civil War Southern generals and
Southern leaders and so we we've pushed
this effort to say we should change
those names and we get into this debate
about you can't it's our history it's
you know blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah and as I've debated this and I
found out what a lot of people don't
realize about that stuff this stuff was
not named in 1870 or 1880 the names came
about in the early 20th century after
reconstruction failed there was a
concerted effort in many parts of this
country to reestablish white supremacy
you go back and you listen to some of
the speeches I think I forget the name
of it this A Stone Mountain Georgia
which is this etching of I think four
Confederate generals
go back to I think like 1910 when it
opened and you listen to the speeches to
the people commemorating that it's a lot
of white supremacy all right it's the
same time that the Klux Clan rose up at
the same time that Jim Crow got put in
place there actually a pretty
interesting book I forget the name of it
I think it's a fever in the Heartland by
Tim Egan about how the clan took over
Indiana okay not talking Alabama I'm
talking Indiana early 20th century in
the fight that had to go to to move that
back so that history exists all right
and we have to wrestle with that history
and figure what does it mean h how do we
better treat people equal and not fall
back into that now I have participated
in some Dei trainings not that many um
and there's two parts of it that I
really like and then I think there's an
incredible missed opportunity the part
that I like is we talk about this
history because a lot of people don't
understand this history I mean they they
don't know it's like well okay the Civil
War happened the North one and there was
you know discrimination in the South and
then everything sort of sorted itself
out well well no actually it didn't um
well into the 70s 80s 90s okay there
were significant problems in all these
areas and if we educate ourselves about
that history we will better understand
our own country and frankly I think
we'll better understand how difficult it
is to achieve the ideals that you talked
about this is what we're trying to do
but it doesn't necessarily come easily
so understand that history and then the
second piece of what they try to do is
and the individual that you're working
with what's their story who are they
okay you know if you are a black person
growing up in America you had a
different experience than if you were a
white person growing up in America and
if you're going to work with somebody
whether it's in an office or a school or
wherever having a conversation and
understanding your colleagues I think is
a very positive thing now where it goes
off the beam in my estimation is it then
sort of talks about how discrimination
and bigotry is unique to white Western
culture okay yeah that yeah that's
pretty that's that's uh right now to
call that wrong is to barely scrape the
surface it's a universal human
proclivity it is but understand that
under the circumstances and there's a
lot of different reasons but white
European culture emerged as the dominant
culture I don't know 19th century
thereabouts actually I'm reading a book
called um when China rules the world uh
it's written in 2009 it's an assumption
about how China's coming and what's it
going to be like and it sort of walks
through this history of you know how and
it it to some degree was an accident of
History you know Guns Germs and Steel
right you know what whatever played out
this particular group of people became
dominant it was white men so therefore
that discrimination was the
Discrimination that dominated a
significant chunk of the globe it's not
irrelevant all right to point out that
that came to pass I think it is more
helpful and and going all the way back
and I'll close with this to your
identity comment what I find most useful
is when we talk about things that talk
about our shared Humanity as opposed to
the things that make us different and of
course we're different of course men are
different from women of course whatever
your cultural background is it's going
to make you a little bit different from
somebody else it's so much better when
we talk about the things that we have in
common and I think one of the things we
have in common no matter who who you are
is a feeling that other people don't
understand you okay I mean that's a
pretty Universal thing in my experience
so if you want to get together and talk
about well here's my experience but we
shouldn't segregate it based on race or
anything like that we should put humans
together and say discrimination bigotry
bias these can be problems you know
let's talk about how we have things in
common instead of how we're different so
I think we could do a lot better but
again the problem is and I we had this
debate in the house arm services
committee on this year's defense bill
now that the Republicans have retaken
the house um I was the chairman of the
committee for four years when Democrats
were in charge now I'm the ranking
member diversity equity and inclusion
was a huge part of the debate and the
debate on the right was we got to get
rid of it Lock Stock and Barrel we just
got to get rid of it um I just think
there's got to be a better answer I
don't necessarily not necessarily I
don't like the way the farle does
diversity equity and inclusion but the
idea that we can just say it's all good
good no racism here no bigotry let's
just move forward and not talk about it
I am at least equally troubled by yeah
well what seems to have happened to me
on the Dei
front especially is
that and this has been partly abetted by
psychologists who put forward the
implicit association test for example
which reports to indicate that the
standard psyche is wired up rif with
implicit biases of sufficient magnitude
to to warp the entire social Enterprise
um these are very weak tests by the way
they're not very valid they're nowhere
near valid enough to be used for
clinical diagnosis because they are very
stringent criteria established to allow
a test to be used for clinical diagnosis
and the accusation of racism is a kind
of diagnosis and you cannot do that with
implicit association test period two of
the people who made the test there are
three have already disavowed their use
for such purposes and so what I see
happening with the Dei movement at least
in some not small part is that people
who are advancing a particular view of
their own moral V virtue and who are
misusing the science in an in what would
you unforgivable manner are elevating
their status in the public domain by
purporting to be compassionate when in
fact all they're doing most of what
they're doing is Feathering their own
nests at the expense of broader social
harmony I see very little good in the
yeah and and I hear that and certainly
you know I people will always try to you
know push the debates you know in in
their favor and I'm as I said I I I go
to Great Links to avoid those sorts of
traps and get back to sort of just
practically what are we trying to
accomplish here I'm I'm thinking as
we're talking about this about the
question that was popular you know and I
may still will be you know do you think
healthc care is a privilege or a right
they'll ask that question as if the
answer has some sort of significant
impact on the quality of your health
care System you know I mean call it what
you want to call it it's a public good
that we need to figure out how to
deliver in the most efficient and
effective way possible let's work on
that but people are always trying to
position themselves if if I can get
people to use the right language I win
okay and the thing is that that's not
entirely wrong okay but it also
distracts from the practical problem
solving of how do we actually improve
things so more so than just about
anybody you're ever going to come across
I will fight against that I will not
answer those sort of well do you believe
it's like let's talk about what we want
to do with the policy I'll talk about
that I'm not going to pick your word or
her word or his word let's just work on
solving the problem but I'll give you
one of the examples that I give a lot of
times about why I think the eii is
important and in my district is kind of
fascinating um I graduated from Tai High
School which is right by CAC Airport my
father was a baggage handler at for
United at seac that's why I grew up
there and when I graduated South King
County which is south of Seattle was a
white blue collar suburb it's what it
was um it has Diversified massively in
the 40 years since I graduated from high
school and one of the things that I've
noticed in the community I'll talk about
me first of all is I don't know I was
like 10 15 years into my career in
Congress when I looked around and
noticed that most of the people who were
working in my office were white
um you know there was no problem between
men and women but and the reason for
that most of the time the first job that
you're going to get is going to be
because you know somebody I mean it does
happen that someone just answers a want
ad and they get a job but for the most
part it's connections that help move you
forward I grew up in an entirely White
Community I came from an entirely white
family the people I Knew by and large
were white the people who I knew knew
were by and large white you know I
wasn't biased against anybody I just
well I was biased in the sense that I
wanted to hire people who I knew and I
looked at this and I said okay this is a
problem now I think a lot of people
would say well no it's not a problem do
you think you're hiring bad people no I
don't think I'm hiring bad people are
you not having a rigor you know no I
think we're doing a decent job it's
still a problem because you're not
reaching out to a broader community so
what my office did is well let's let's
work with some Community groups and
there's a variety of different you know
there's a thing called Taber 100 that
tries to help um African-American
business people and I'd worked with them
a lot there's the black collective in
Tacoma there's El Centra de laza that
works with the Hispanic Community a
variety of different groups and I said
when we have a job opening now what I'm
going to do is I'm going to reach out to
them I'm going to say I got this
position who you got and it Diversified
my my Workforce it es and flows for a
whole bunch of different reasons um I
think it's really important that you and
I'm going to go ahead and use a
left-wing word here it's about the only
one that I like um you have to be
intentional and I believe in that you
know if you're trying to get something
done it doesn't happen by accident so
you have to affirmatively reach out in
that way and I think we need to have
those types of programs and a lot of
times people yeah well your I I would
say just on technical grounds your
argument is is correct in relationship
to confidence because the case you're
laying out essenti is that because of
the ethnocentric structure of your
connection network there were
potentially qualified candidates that
you are unlikely to come into contact
with and so by diversifying your
Outreach in relationship to candidate
selection you are able to in principle
find more qualified people because it's
a broader pool and with a subsidiary
with the subsidiary benefit of
potentially providing a Workforce that
was more representative of the community
but it seems to me that all of that can
be accomplished by the mere mere
observation that a broader and more
differentiated candidate pool All Things
Considered is technically preferable
rather than
concentrating particularly on on Equity
issues and Equity this is another thing
that I've talked to Democrats across the
country about and most particularly in
Washington Equity is a word that really
disturbs me because Equity fundamentally
means equality of outcome and equality
of outcome is a very bad idea because
there's no difference between inequality
of outcome and ownership like if you own
something that means that you have an
unequal access to it in relationship to
someone else and there's no way of
eradicating inequality without
eradicating ownership per se and the
notion that we can calculate the
fairness of our society by it dividing
people subdividing people into their
group identities and checking every
single Enterprise to make sure that
proportionality exists which would be
impossible in any case definitely puts
the cart before the horse and and it and
I also see in the term equity and of
course Christopher rufo was concentrated
on this too that's the place that I see
the most radical form of Quasi Marxist
idation invading the the the Democratic
discussion so that's concern and so I I
both agree with you and disagree with
you on this point I think if you if you
well the the way I disagree with you is
equity equality they mean a lot of
different things okay back to my
whenever well ask ask me are you a
socialist I don't what do you mean okay
you know equity and equality are the
same kind of the same way they can mean
a lot of different things if you just
say I'm for Equity or I'm against Equity
you haven't added anything to the
conversation whatsoever now where it is
true is what you said there is a certain
segment of the leftwing political world
that is defined equity in a very
specific way that has sort of got them
wrapped up in a lot of confusion because
when you get past the point where it's
okay you can certainly Focus I mean okay
I'm to get myself in trouble here uh but
the two most discriminated groups in
America broadly speaking are um black
people and Native Americans okay you
know if you're want to start somewhere
in terms of where who America has
treated poorly uh that's a pretty good
place to start uh but it goes beyond
that okay well what about you know
recent immigrants um what yeah how do
you salami slice it past a certain point
let's say okay you've improved Equity
you have more people of color in your
office but you don't have any
asian-americans okay or you could go
right down forther okay you've got a
bunch of people from India but you don't
have many people from Southeast I mean
you can go down that road to the point
where it's impossible to achieve that
and I think that has in many instances
happened and that is is is a challenge
however I don't think equity and
equality are well Irrelevant for I think
equity and equality are things that we
need to work towards okay not in the
sense that you just described where
Equity means absolutely everybody
regardless of anything has everything
the same that's ridiculous okay but if
you simply go the equality of outcome
route then you're you're you're leaving
out a whole bunch of stuff that comes
before you get a chance to have that
outcome yeah well that's for sure so so
we need to think about that and we need
to think about in that case historical
racism historical discrimination
redlining okay whole bunch of different
things do factor into what the outcome
is today this is very difficult because
no simple way to do this there's no
formula that you're going to come up
with you in fact one of the big things
that I frequently say problem we have in
the world if you are after perfect
Justice then you are going to be any
permanent state of War I have this Vivid
image in my mind of mosovich back in
1988 when you know on what I think was
the 600th anniversary of the battle of
Koso where long story short the um uh
the serbs got their asses kicked um by
somebody and they've been bitter about
it ever since and they were going to
they were going to write that wrong 600
years later and a number of people got
slaughtered over the course th you
because of that fight all right if
you're constantly focused on everything
has to be Equitable then you're in a bad
place if on the other hand just sort of
shrug and go well you know not anything
we need to worry about you're also going
to be in trouble and I just think that
the human mind is in fact capable of
striking that balance without having to
choose one side or the other okay we can
work and say okay here's a group of
people that don't seem to be achieving
is it the case that they're somehow just
inferior no okay so let's think
creatively how can we be more inclusive
how can we help them get to a better
outcome knowing that it's never going to
be perfectly equal it seems to me
certainly in American politics I don't
know anything about Canadian politics so
I will not speak to that that we've just
set up this false choice you know either
you have to be a full-on equity identity
politics farle person or you have to be
on the right and not care about it at
all you know and you know that that
Dynamic is something that I'm trying to
fight is to get to people say no we we
can find a more reasonable place in
between here um it doesn't have to be
this death match between two extreme
ideologies yeah well you you make a
constant case in your conversation with
me today for differentiation and
diagnosis I mean one of the problems is
is that it's easy for us for everyone to
abstract a problem way too far up the
abstraction hierarchy and to talk about
such things for example as health care
when in fact there's no such thing as
healthc care there's 10,000 different
variants of caring for people Each of
which is a complex problem on its own
and you can understand why people would
rather have a one- siiz fits-all
solution because yeah well if you could
have that it would be wonderful and it
certainly decreases the cognitive comp
lexity but it is necessary and
challenging to differentiate I wanted to
turn to something can
I question before we move off because
I'm interested in your cognitive take on
this because you know my my my Shand to
all of this you know it's a quote that I
I quote in my book um I always misquote
it because I prefer it this way but Sue
Grafton who was a mystery writer she
wrote the a toz um uh the Kinsey mahol
Mysteries she want Wonder of her book
she said thinking's hard work that's why
most people people don't do it um you
know I'm sort of torn between that and
also a passionate belief that if we
engage and take on difficult problems we
get more joy out of it okay that that
that we don't have to accept the fact
well let's dumb everything down because
nobody wants to work hard um I just
don't I don't I don't really believe
that and actually there's a professor at
uh Yale University uh I think it's Dr
Santos who teaches a class on happiness
um it's it's the most highly subscribed
class apparently in the history of of
Yale and her big point is what makes us
happy is to be productive but our Basic
Instinct is to not be productive so we
have we have to work work through that
and just from a you know someone like
yourself who you know has much more
medical background than I do you why
can't we get the human brain to to
embrace that a little bit more well take
on to see complexity as is a good thing
not a bad thing that's what I'm trying
to say well you you po well you you you
put your finger on a fundamental problem
the problem of complexity the problem of
complexity is essentially that there's
there's far more entropy in the cosmos
in the world than there is
organizational capacity in the psyche
right because things overwhelm us and
that's actually a technical problem
because if you're exposed involuntarily
to a situation that's
complex you will manifest a stress
response and that's accompanied by an
increase for example in the production
of cortisol and what that does is start
to have you burn up resources that you
could be saving for future use now and
if if you're chronically stressed you
will age there's very little difference
between those two things and so if
you're exposed to Too Much complexity
especially
involuntarily it will it will take you
out physiologically
psychophysiologically and so people are
very motivated to avoid it then well let
me add one more let me add one more
detail to that because while it's the
rest of the answer to your question so
then you might ask yourself well how do
you calibrate the optimal amount of
exposure to complexity and the answer to
that technically seems to be by moving
towards something approximating the
spirit of voluntary play so now you and
I like we have agreements and
disagreements in the way that we map the
world and what we're doing and I think
we've done this successfully so far in
this conversation is to push each other
in an optimized manner that enables
something approximating the spirit of
cooperative and competitive play to
emerge right and you can tell that's
happening because to the degree that
we're successful at it we're deeply
grossed in the conversation and we're
developing as a consequence of doing
that and so I believe and that the
Instinct of meaning and it manifests
itself for example in play the Instinct
of meaning is exactly the Instinct that
tells you when you're optimizing your
confrontation with complexity yeah
here's the interesting thing about that
to me going back to my my psychological
problems and my anxiety um and what
Psychotherapy ultimately did for me I
believe that you can train the brain to
better deal with complexity something
somebody said to me and I mentioned this
in my book early on was that it's not
the amount of stress in your life it's
how you process it now at the time she
told me that I was in the early stages
of my second bout with crippling anxiety
and I completely rejected what she said
my whole life had been a combination
between on the one hand I was incredibly
ambitious I wanted a lot out of my life
so I had to push myself to get there and
I understood that but even as I I was
doing that I sort of thought of it as
I've got I've got a tank here all right
and I'm going to use it up and then I'm
done okay and then I got to retreat and
I got and so in my early battles to deal
with anxiety I was focused on okay what
can I sort of declutter my life right
how can I do how can I change things so
I don't have as much stress but the
central Insight she gave me that Insight
it took me several years and three and a
half years with the Psychotherapy to
understand it um is she's right it is
not amount of complexity in your life it
is how you process it and that's the
basics to my mind of simple meditation I
say simple meditation because complex
meditation is something I've never been
able to do meditation is not about
eliminating every thought in your head
okay I thought that for the longest time
it's a very it's a very difficult thing
to do and it will drive you crazy um you
know I'm meditating I medit oh my gosh I
had a thought I failed um not the way to
do it the point is a whole lot of
stuff's going to come at you every
single day it's coming at you all right
right thoughts feeling sounds you have
to teach yourself to be able to from
time to time just sort of let it bounce
off okay notice it and move on so you
know we could walk down a road here I
know you want to go in a different
direction but that's what I find most
interesting about the brain is I think
you can teach it it's not just okay
here's here's my complexity jar once it
hits here I'm out okay I think you can
train your brain to better process
complexity and in that sense
I think basic mental health has a lot to
do with some of our broader societal
problems well you're you made a case
there that you could imagine that you
could protect yourself against being
swamped by entropy you could protect
yourself against complexity by
defensively armoring yourself for
example and by Walling yourself off from
complex problems that idea goes along
with the kind of Zero Sum mentality that
you also Des described which is well I
have a limited amount of resource and
when that's exhausted I'm done and so I
better be careful now we know that's not
true for example and and I think this is
best Illustrated when you think about
people playing a game is that if you are
playing one-on-one basketball with
someone you're going to want to find
somebody who's about as good as you are
or slightly better and the reason for
that is because you might want to win
but actually what you want to do is get
better at playing
basketball and the same is true of the
proper attitude towards complexity like
people often wall themselves off and
defend themselves and Retreat because
they're afraid they'll be overwhelmed
but you can teach people and you do this
through graduated exposure and
incremental Improvement you can teach
people to stay on the edge an edge they
Define right an edge of competence and
in consequ quence what happens is that
their capacity to deal with complexity
continues to expand and that's really a
process of optimized maturation and
what's fun about that I love this being
a clinician is that there's nothing more
engrossing and entertaining than helping
someone negotiate to a point where they
can discover that it's the edge between
Chaos and Order by the way the
developmental Edge it's the zone of
proximal development to help people
discover that and learn to stay there
there isn't anything more rewarding than
that and there isn't anything that
expands people's competence and social
competence more than having that occur
this is also part of the problem with
such things as trigger warnings and and
the protection of students say in the
University environment because you don't
want protection and safety you want
optimized challenge because that
increases your
competence yeah no I think that that
makes a great deal of sense so but you
were going somewhere else before I took
us in this direction why do you think
you were res resistant to that or why do
you think that hadn't occurred to you
because you you intimated that much when
you were dealing with the an anxiety
problems that you had where do you think
the inculcation of that idea that you
had in some ways limited Zero Sum
resources where do you think that came
from that assumption and how did you
successfully challenge it well I I I
literally think that the reason I had
that Outlook is because the other thing
hadn't occurred to
me okay you know and so and that's why
again why enjoy having these
conversations it frequently happens in
my life that I will have a very strong
opinion about something maybe I've
thought about it for years decades and
and then someone will say something that
it's like huh had thought of that before
let s of play that out so I think was a
big part of it um and I just think it
was just it was just sort of my
mentality because Stress and Anxiety
that was that was who I was okay you
know I I was not walking into a
stressful event you know it was just it
was part of me I would think about it
worry about it and so and I outlined
this in the book I I the strategy that I
came up with actually there's one other
reason why I felt this the strategy I
came up with I describe as think think
think worry worry worry work work work
that basically that was my Approach if I
wanted to get somewhere and there was a
problem I had to go after it okay and I
was supposed to be stressed I was
supposed to be worried if I wasn't
stressed if I wasn't worried
um then I wasn't doing something
important all right and that became
mentality and I think the biggest reason
why I struggled to let go of that is
aside from the mental problems um I was
spectacularly successful okay I won a
number of campaigns that were a number
let's be fair I won three campaigns that
were extraordinarily difficult but
changed my life all right and I was able
to succeed you know I have a happy
marriage I have good you know my good
relationship with my children KN on
would as we say that um everything you
know everything's good and I thought
this is how I succeed and if you're
going to come along and tell me that I
got to do something
different I really felt like you know
that would make it less likely that I
would be successful that you know yes
okay maybe I wouldn't be crazy um but I
also sorry that's a pejorative term but
um maybe I would wouldn't have the
anxiety problem um but I'd also wouldn't
and I was so wrong about that so so it
sounds to me like you had you had fallen
into the
presumption and correct me if I've got
this wrong that there was no difference
between your laudable moral striving and
being stressed that stress was a marker
that right right and so and so you had
presumed that in order to actively cope
and be successful there was no respite
from
being overwhelmed by complexity and by
and being stressed and what the
therapist did for you at least in part
was to lay out for you the fact that you
could progress forward effectively
without having to Bear the burden of
constant crippling stress is that and
that's the yeah that's biggest message I
want to try to get to people because I
used to say it's the stuff I don't worry
about that gets me in trouble and I also
used to like to say I believe in the
power of negative thinking uh which was
you know if I worry oh my gosh what can
go wrong what can go wrong you know and
you know and so that's what I believed I
had to do when in fact there you can be
every little bit as intense every little
bit as focused on getting a task done
without having to feel physically
stressed out so what did you do
specifically to start making changes in
that direction we talked a little bit
about the utility of incremental
progress and this is obviously tied in
to our broader discussion about facing
ideas say on the political and
conceptual front that challenge you
there there's a very tight relationship
between these things but I'm very
curious you you you report in your book
that you had an anxious temperament we
somewhat shy and introverted from a very
early age so it's a deeply it's a it's
deeply ingrained inside you that that
propensity for negative emotional
response how concretely how was it that
you changed the way you were approaching
things that actually made a difference
and why do you think those changes were
what made the difference yeah it was
ultimately a couple of things three and
a half years worth of psychotherapy
which I'll get into in a minute second
it was getting off of the various forms
of medication that I had been on um but
most importantly the the problem that I
had is sort of a Baseline and this is
incredibly important for psychology um
and Psychiatry um there are three basic
basic steps in my view to getting to
good mental health number one was the
one that I completely missed and that is
to have an inherent sense of your own
selfworth this is what I didn't grasp I
thought my self-worth was was a
measurable thing on a day in and day out
basis all right and by whatever
measurement you want to come by you know
was I doing my job well okay was I a
good husband was I a good father you
know was I being responsible did I make
a smart decision here did I do that so
every day I was trying to judge okay how
am I doing all right when in fact an
incredibly important Concept in our
psychology is it's a Buddhist thing for
the most part we are all worthy of love
we all have self-worth and that
self-worth is not dependent upon our
deeds and in the three and a half years
with the Psychotherapy was me arguing
with my psychologist on this point
because the biggest sticking point for
me on this was wait a second you're
telling me it doesn't matter what we do
okay that you know somebody who's
completely irr I'm very responsible
person my my wife and I have have this
in common she's the eldest of five
children and she fits that that oldest
child measurement quite quite well we
believe in meeting our responsibilities
so you're telling me that if I don't
meet my responsibilities if I don't
follow the rule if I that I'm just as
good as if I if I don't of course that's
not actually what they're telling you
all right you should always you can work
to be better at things but it's not an
existential Threat all right just
because you make a mistake could do
something wrong doesn't mean that your
basic self worth as a human being is out
the window I didn't understand that okay
I was working my whole life every day to
prove that I was worthy so having
someone walk me through that and explain
to me was was the number one biggest
thing and then the second biggest thing
in Psychiatry is to really understand
who you are and I love this quote about
Psychotherapy which I quote in my book
which is that the purpose of
psychotherapy is not to correct the past
it is to help the patient understand his
history and to grieve for what he has
lost I wanted to correct the past and
the very specific past I wanted to
correct was my screwed up family okay
and there are families that are more
screwed up than others and I don't walk
through the whole story I was adopted
you know and my and it just fell apart
by the time I was like 12 or 14 my older
brother you know we became he had
criminal problems he had drug problems
he was out control my parents were
stressed out out indoor depressed my
father died when I was 19 my mother died
you know a few years after that and just
felt like this complete epic failure and
then after all of that happened my life
you know I got elected to the state
senate I met my wife everything went
fine and I was like okay don't have to
worry about that anymore when in fact it
was still bugging me okay it was bugging
me both in terms of you know well why
didn't my family do a better job of
handling this and then crucially it was
also bugging me from the standpoint of
if I'm holding myself out as a leader in
the community you know as someone who
gets things done and all these other
positive things you know about my career
the hell did I do about that the whole
thing fell apart while I was there okay
and I never really resolved that so we
talked through that and that helped
resolve that that's a big thing now in
in um well with PTSD and other things um
you have to be able to resolve issues in
your past and some of it is traumatic
we're talking real trauma but even if
it's not trauma in the classic sense of
the word things that have really bugged
you bring them out in the open deal with
them and that can dramatically reduce
anxiety and depression and there's a
variety of different therapies now
EMDR um there's a new thing that they're
working with um in the military in
particular and I hope I get the initials
right um
etm um which is another way of sort of
rewiring your brain through conversation
to look at these events in your life in
a different way so those are the two big
things the biggest problem we have in
Psychology in America um and I I don't
want to take us too far down this road
if you have political things you want to
talk about and happy to answer them is
we start with cognitive behavioral
therapy and to my mind probably 90% of
the time that's a mistake that's what
they did with me that's why I cycled
through so many psychiatrists and
psychologists and cognitive behavioral
therapy is important you need to figure
out how to better process things coming
in and you understand exactly what it is
you're worried about or depressed about
how to handle it but if you don't deal
with those two Baseline things first
cognitive behavioral therapy is just
going to piss you off all right because
it's not going to seem like it's working
I the analogy I came up with just a
couple days ago it's like if you break
your leg you can say physical therapy is
important and it's going to be important
but if you don't set the leg first okay
and then tell someone okay start doing
these exercises it's not going to work
very well so I just don't think we have
that order correct so so that you were
you were suffering by your own admission
from a very fundamental theological
dilemma I would say and so you could
imagine that there are ways of
justifying your miserable existence so
to speak and one would be justification
through works and that is the proclivity
that conscientious people have
conscientious and responsible people
which is that they derive their sense of
worth worth from an evaluation of their
continued contributions and as you said
there's some real utility in that
because you should be responsible and um
generous productivity is laudable and
it's reasonable to observe how you're
doing in that regard and to evaluate
yourself to some degree on that basis
but if that's all the is then you are
missing another important theological
presupposition and I I'm speaking about
those as fundamental presuppositions
akin to setting your leg before you
start worrying about physiotherapy is
that you know there is an axiomatic
presupposition that underlies the
ethical Corpus of the West that every
person is made in the image of God and
has intrinsic worth and that means that
you know if you think about those as
balanced you could say well of course I
should strive forward and make the
appropriate sacrifices and be useful to
myself and my community but underneath
that this is probably what's provided by
the way in the final analysis by the
proper kind of maternal love you know
that that kind of all-encompassing love
is that regardless of your flaws you
have you have an intrinsic worth that's
inviable that you can always return to
as a as a source of what replenishment
and self-confidence right that sense of
intrinsic worth and you know if you
don't the interesting thing too is that
if you don't apply that to yourself it's
also very difficult to apply it to other
people so yeah yeah and so that and
that's where I cross cross over into
public policy okay that's you know and I
I make that point at the end of my book
exactly is you know what really helps
Cur you as well as everyone else yes you
have selfworth but think about that that
means everybody else does too even the
person who's from the different
political party if you're pro-choice
even the person who's pro- life okay
whatever the issue and if you believe
that it makes our society get together
better and frankly that's you know you
ask why I wanted to do this interview
certainly I find you very smart I I love
intellectual conversation just in
general you have a good following it
gives me an opportunity to get an
audience but I think one thing in
particular about what you teach that I
think is so important that really has
come to me as I've looked at the broader
mental health issues is the idea of
getting better and that that needs to be
the f Focus cuz a lot of people talk
about the stigma around mental health
and I've had a lot of interviews about
that and I think that is important we're
getting better on that we're more
willing to talk about it but there still
is a a stigma that will stop people from
wanting to seek treatment but the other
piece of it is If all we're doing is
talking about mental health problems If
all we're doing in essence is wallowing
in it and saying okay now I have
something identifiable for why I'm so
hopelessly screwed up um or just sort of
boeris looking at it what really gives
me going as you can see is what I
learned throughout this process about
how you can get better and I think your
basic point I watched a video you I
can't more was in titled anyway it's the
basic point of every day try to make
yourself better and that will make you
happier and you will get better and and
there's a bunch of different ways to
balance it but I worry to that in
America a lot of it on Mental Health has
become like I said this is why I messed
up okay so no this is a diagnosis so
that you can get better and I think a
lot of the messages you talk about start
small okay you know you're not going to
solve The World's problems don't compare
yourself to other people compare
yourself to yourself and what you want
to be and what you want to do but work
to get better I think is such a crucial
message for the mental health of of
society well it's especially one of the
things that was really really gratifying
about working as a psychotherapist was
watching what happened when people did
begin to take incremental steps forward
and
there it was often an exercise in like a
painful humility you know because if
you're weak in an
area when you start moving forward you
have to take very small steps and it's a
humbling experience often to Grapple
with the fact that the only thing you're
capable of doing is that tiny step
forward you know something absurd if I
counseled my clients for example to work
on maybe I'd have a client who was 30
and still lived in his parents in the
bedroom he was in in high school and it
was a complete bloody mess because he'd
never done anything to keep it orderly
in his whole life and he's 30 you know
and so there's an element of that that's
pretty damn pathetic and we'd have to
struggle to find the level at which he
could grapple with that problem and so
the injunction go clean up your room and
come back next week to the therapy
session and tell me it's done was
completely useless because it might have
been that he was only capable because
that because there was a big problem of
lurking dependency there of cleaning up
half his sock drawer and to realize that
that's the best you can do is pretty
damn humbling but the upside and this is
what's so cool this is part of the
Matthew principle right to those who
have everything more will be given is
that once you start improving that
Improvement accelerates geometrically
not linearly and so even if you have to
start with virtually nothing that
doesn't mean that you won't accelerate
extraordinarily rapidly and that's so
fun it's so fun to help people do that
because they take these tiny steps
forward in humility let's say and then
very rapidly they're they're the length
of Step they can take
it
lengthens remarkably well and that and
that's you know going back to our equity
and equality conversation that's
something that I've always passionately
believed in and this is one of the down
sides of sort of the American
meritocracy thing okay and and we're
wrestling this with this now is you know
we've gotten rid of affirmative action
or any sort of race based stuff in
colleges based on the Supreme Court and
now everyone's looking at well what
about legacies you know what about the
the guy who plays badminton and now he
gets in is I do think in America you can
go too far in this whole meritocracy
thing you know if you have stuff that
means you're better okay well maybe um
and maybe not number one number two and
I believe this everybody is capable of
of doing better okay and throughout my
life you know I didn't go to a ivy leak
school I grew up in a very blue collar
neighborhood those you know and I see my
friends from that neighborhood who have
gone on done some pretty cool things
with their life all right and I think
too often in America we're like we're
trying constantly trying to call the top
okay you know it's like oh this guy's
the best you know he got 1,600 in the
SAT and it's like and I think one of the
things that motivated me I I had a 32 in
high school I had an 11 an 1190 on the
SAT as a matter of fact figuring out how
to beat those people who got A600 in the
SAT brings me an enormous amount of Joy
okay and I've done it throughout my life
you know and so when I see other people
people oh gosh you know he's not that
smart you he's going didn't go to
college whatever it's like no if you
really see people all right and work
with them what they're capable of is
incredible and so I get frustrated with
both the right and the left on this I
get frustrated with the left that sees
people like this and says oh you know
you you have to be really care with this
person they can't really do anything you
you can't put any pressure on them you
know I just that's not my experience and
then on the right when it's like well
that person doesn't deserve to be here
you know they haven't done this they
haven't done that they haven't gotten
the
scores let's just give a little bit here
and we'll see what what folks are
capable of and that's what I really
really want to deliver and it's been my
experience in life is you know help
people it's funny you know that in some
ways it was your proclivity to engage in
that kind of let's say right-wing
meritocratic thinking that was actually
contributing in no small part to the
acceleration of your anxiety it's so
interesting to see that given that you
know you thought that before but yes
well well yeah well and I mean that is
the problem with a with with a strict
mer with a with with a a strict and
narrowly defined meritocracy is that
right it privileges being over becoming
that's a good way of thinking about it
and you know and what you were talking
about the 1190
sat you know one of the things there's
no doubt that intellectual prowess as
measured by such tests is a deadly
accurate predictor of long-term success
it leaves about 34 of the success domain
unaccounted for by the way but it is
also the case that vision and hard work
can go an awful long way to redressing
that difference in say initial starting
point and so and that is something I do
want to give you what I happen to be
reading a Malcolm Gladwell uh article
and this is probably was this his book
of essays so was probably 20 years ago
when he wrote it but and this gets back
into some of the racial issues that we
face he was attempting to explain the
difference between panicking and choking
um which is not terribly relevant here
um but one of the things he analyzed was
Stanford did a study I forget when it
was that they did this where they gave
the same test with two different
explanations the first time they gave
the test they said this is an IQ test
this is to measure you know how smart
you are basically how capable and when
they gave that test they gave it to
black students and white students the
white students performed significantly
better than the black students but when
they gave the same test and said this is
a survey it isn't measuring anything we
just want to know how you respond to
these questions they performed at the
exact same level and the reason they
surmised was because of a lot of the
stigma in society the reputation oh you
know black students can't do well on on
standardized tests that the black
students felt a lot more pressure okay
they're like oh my gosh this is
something I'm not good at so you know I
better figure this out I better and they
and I I always get the panicking choking
thing mixed up there one of them is
thinking too much the other one one is
just ah choking choking is when you
think too much panicking is when you
stop thinking altogether um and they
kind of kind of choked because they okay
I got to think through this I got to be
you know and that's just not the right
way to take that test and it shows both
that you know this notion of inherent
you know capability one way or the other
is ridiculous number one and number two
we have a long way to go to overcome
some of the racial stereotypes in both
directions to move towards a more
Equitable Society if you'll forgive me
using that word well your your
criticisms earlier about the
conservative side of things I think are
appro there too is that um one of the
ways that we overcome the
[Music]
built-in inadequacies of the current
system is to provide people with a
vision and one of the things that the
left has done much more effectively than
the right is to provide a vision you
know of equality equity and Harmony and
and movement towards something
approximating a Utopia whereas the
right's vision is generally something
like less of less interference is better
and there's some truth in that but it's
not a vision right it's it's the it's
the absence of a set of constraints and
um it would be lovely to see the left
and the right engage in the kind of
dialogue that would uh produce a
compelling Vision that both sides could
could engage in I want to close because
we have to close this side of the
conversation fairly soon I I want to
close with one more political question
if you don't mind sure it's been very
interesting to me to see the response by
the Two Front Runners in the 2024
presidential campaign respond to the the
possibility of engaging in debate I mean
Biden has as as far as I know has
indicated quite clearly that he's not
going to participate in any primary
debates and now we have Trump making
exactly the same statement on the
Republican side and to me first of all
this I think this is very bad I think
it's cowardly on both their parts and I
think it's also a huge mistake
because leaders should model that right
if you're a leader if you're a genuine
leader and you can listen and you can
negotiate you should model that for your
people on the stage and so I'm I'm I
think it's a missed opportunity and and
I think it's a form of instrumental
Behavior as well because both Biden and
Trump are assuming well we're the Front
Runners and we have we have we have
nothing except loss on the debate side
and you know that's that's not a
position that's associated in my
estimation with confidence and Authority
because the proper attitude should be
well number one the people deserve to
hear us put our ideas forward and to
have them challenged period and number
two well if you're the guy well why not
take the opportunity to indicate that
and so what do you think about the fact
that you know the Two Front Runners have
dropped out of the
debate out of the they they've forgone
the debate opportunities well I have
multiple thoughts about that as I
alluded to earlier it's always been my
philosophy let's engage and I'm never
afraid of engaging anywhere anytime
asking what whatever question comes
comes at me I mean was I was doing a
forum at the Brooking Institute talking
about um I think it was Ukraine
specifically and the code pink people
storm the stage and tried to shut it
down This Woman's yelling and asking a
question and I and I just said I said
you know actually I think that's a
really good question I'd love to have
the conversation which of course she did
not want to have um but so I think in
general engage all right as much as you
possibly can and number two from a
political standpoint I'm a huge sports
fan so I tend to use Sports analogies
we've gotten almost through this entire
interview without me using one but you
know if you're ahead and you're playing
not to lose you're losing that's always
been my philosophy you know you got to
play to win every second every play it's
funny I think I think my wife could hear
this but it's the way I watch baseball
and she's like my gosh you would think
this was the World Series it's one
inning and one game and I'm like you
know and I'm focused on it all right
because I just think you know you got to
try to be doing your best at every
second you get ahead and think you're
going to hold on and I can't exactly
explain it but I've played enough you
know games in my life to know
psychologically once you get to that
place where you're trying to hold on
instead of trying to win You're
vulnerable so you don't or trying to
improve or trying to improve right
because well the thing is you think
about what's happened psychologically
here's what's happened is you've shifted
into a defensive stance exactly and that
means all challenge will now be
experienced as stress now if you reverse
that and say of course I'll take the
opportunity to debate then you're taking
on the challenge voluntarily and that
that produces an entirely different set
of not only psychophysiological
responses because it's a challenge
rather than a threat but it also
broadcasts a kind of confidence in your
own ability to progress that's part and
parcel of being willing to engage it's a
much better measure it's a much better
indication of leadership concretely
right merely the willingness to get into
the frey so we did today yes exactly so
I agree with you mistake the other part
of it though that that I spent a lot of
time wondering about try to be careful
about this but you know speaking is is
something that I'm good at um I'm it's
you know my whole life I've been able to
articulate ideas in in a comfortable and
effective way and I think that is an
important part of leadership but then
you know and this is my my egalitarian
side I guess what what makes me more on
the left side of the political Spectrum
I'm like well is it really the case if
you just happen to not be that
articulate that you're necessarily a
worse leader okay is that the case you
know maybe you've got the ideas maybe
you're good in a crisis you work with a
team and do all that but standing up and
giving a speech not the thing you're
best at and I've certainly worked with
colleagues by the way who in a million
years I wouldn't want to be sitting on
the floor listening to them give a
speech but I know there's someone that I
can count on I know that they they're
going to do the work they know the
issues they'll work together so is a
public debate really the one way to
figure out who's going to best lead a
community um I think we fall a little
bit in love with that idea I always
think of a quote that Dennis Miller had
about Michael Dukakis um about how
Michael Dukakis never really had a
chance because he lacked that
superficial Charisma that we seem to
look for in our leaders um you know so
I'm mindful of that as well I I I think
people place too much emphasis on the
debates um so all that said I still
think they should do it I guess the
final criticism I have is the debate
debate formats are difficult this
conversation between you and I is
dependent upon both of us being
reasonable with the other person you
know yeah I'm not going to talk over you
you're not going to talk if you have a
question you'll interject it but you do
it in a polite and respectful way you
know you look at the debate that Trump
and Biden had the first one when yeah I
mean is that really useful when there's
no construct and then they said well you
got one minute one minute and then
you're done well okay how how
informative is that all right when when
I I love chairing the arm Services
committee because I tried to run it in a
fair way all right I would include
people in the conversation and not
everyone got the same amount of time all
the time because that's that's not how
you have a good conversation you need a
moderator who's honestly trying to make
sure that we get the issues out in a
fair and balanced way and I guess I
would is that possible
in today's era is it possible to do that
in a way that the two candidates aren't
just going to be shouting over each
other in an unproductive way I don't
know well you know I'm really I'm really
hopeful with regards to political
communication on the long form with
regards to long-term format podcasts
because they give people the opportunity
to speak in an unscripted manner
relatively deeply spontaneously right
which which is a good way of detecting
both ability and the proclivity to uh to
deceive and to deepen the political
conversation and you know we had these
terrible restrictions on broadcast
accessibility that were part and parcel
of the Legacy TV environment but that's
all gone and so now there's no reason
even for debates you know there's there
would be no reason whatsoever not to
hold a forum of this sort with a variety
of different candidates and actually
have a
conversation because you don't have to
the thing about debates is they're very
Tim limited instruct ured and you can
see why that's necessary when television
bandwidth is hyper expensive but in some
ways there's no reason for that anymore
anyways we should stop I'm going to for
everybody watching and listening I'm
going to continue talking to Congressman
Smith on The Daily wire side and we'll
do what I usually do there and delve
into issues that are more
autobiographical um I think that's
particularly gerain in this case because
of um Congressman Smith's new book lost
and broken my journey back from chronic
pain and crippling anxiety we're going
to talk about that in some more detail
on The Daily we plus side thank you very
much for agreeing to talk to me
hopefully that'll set a trend on the
Democrat side I guess we'll find out or
at least somewhat of a trend because it
would be lovely to be able to have
discussions that reach across the aisle
and and to attempt to reverse some of
this terrible proclivity towards
polarization that really threatens the
Integrity I would say of the West the
Integrity of the US the Integrity of
West more broadly so it's much
appreciated um for everyone watching and
listening please join us on the daily
Weare plus side for an additional half
an hour and uh thank you to the
dailywire Plus for making this
conversation possible pleasure to talk
to you sir likewise I appreciate the
chance thank
[Music]
you